okay take a I mean thingy take one  something anyway hey I thought that was  really good thanks don't mean like ever  attack you what is it not too painful  yeah you know what's wrong with that hat  my grandmother had it well did your  grandmother hike to a tee  I bet you still wear that hat most men  just you know I'll lose their mind at a  certain age you know most men lower  their standards as they age you have  actually written to you yeah it's a Sun  Hat yeah listen it's great for jazz but  not for this element hyejin chance I kid  my name's not cats  oh hi should be nervous head over there  vomiting flubber were you in there boy  come on you [ __ ] it was good  until you start digging into it and  timber land is a wrapper that I really  enjoy  oh my lord you know how much film we  have to burn here I don't care  you